>> Marc: YES, THE AVS WILL B B H
SHOT.
GAME.
TONIGHT, St. LOUIS HAS COME
OUT AND THEY HAVE HAD SOME
REALLY GOOD CHICAGO
WE KIND OF FORGOTTEN ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THEY HAVE BEEN IN THE
ZONE A LLKS IN AND
SHOOTS.
OFF IRON.
AVS COULDN'T GET THE PUCK AWAYNT
AND DAVID PERRON.
EVERY BLUES GOAL HAS THEY WERE
COMING BUT TWO QUICK GOALS BY
THE St. LOUIS SCORES!
ANDRE BURAKOVSKY ON A PERFECT OE
PICTURE?E.
BURAKOVSKY O O COMPHER.
THAT IS SPECTACULAR. CENTERING .
O'CONNOR CAN!
SAVE.
LOOK, 57 GOILAST SHIFT OF AN NH.
AND C SHOT ON
NET BY COMPHER AND JOE IS
SCORING.
THOSE TWO GUYS,
BACK TO
SEND THE GAME INTO
CALE.
OVER TO IT OR WAS
IT JUST GOING IN. A MOMENT FOR
JOST AND COMPHER IF THIS
>> Marc: LET'S LISTE
AT AND HE SKATES IT IN.
SO THE AVS WERE GAME HERE IN
THE T IT?
>> Marc: OH, HE MISSED.
>>